In this lesson,
you learned about scaling and
deploying clusters into the cloud.
Using these features of Cooper Nettie's
makes cloud applications more resilient,
and now you can finally
call them production ready.
Looking back over this course, you
learned about modern application design.
You learn best practices for
using decorative package and
distribute containers.
And you learned how to manage and
scale containers Cooper Nettie's.
>> And for many of you, this is the
first container you've ever built, and
it's the first cluster you've
ever deployed, according to for,
I expect great things from you, and
if you do, I'll come to your job, and
do the Cooper Nettie's dance
[MUSIC]
>> It's been a lot of fun learning and
growing with you.
[MUSIC]